- So Scott, thank you very
much for visiting us virtually.
So Scott Williamson is a
political scientist and he's in
the Department of Social
Political Sciences at Bocconi.
And today we'll hear
about people's perceptions
and attitudes towards migrants
and, you know, Scott, so,
you know, you're,
we discussed you're in a
interdisciplinary audience
and this seminar is generally
very interdisciplinary,
so last week we had an
anthropology speaking,
the previous week, an economist speaking,
and so we tend to get
participation from people
in different disciplines
and, you know, and sometimes,
you know, of course disciplinary
like cultures vary and
sometimes, you know, people might
just unmute themselves and ask a question
if there's something like
clarifying, they wanna...
All right, thank you, please take it away.
Oh, and Teresa also
wanted me to announce that
we're now doing a survey on the seminars
so she'll put the link in the chat
so if the participants can just click
and provide us your feedback.
That'd be great, thank you.
- Great, thanks so much.
Thank you for those of you who are here.
Thank you to the program
for the opportunity to share my work.
The title of the project
is Combining Perspective-
Getting with Information Delivery
to Increase Public Support for Refugees.
This is joint work with a team of scholars
who I've worked with
previously on related projects,
Claire Adida and Lauren Prather at UCSD,
Adeline Lo at University
of Wisconsin-Madison,
and Melina Platas at New
York University Abu Dhabi.
So I'm very lucky to be working with them
and we all look forward to
any feedback you might have.
And I'm completely happy to
take questions throughout,
so please feel free to
interrupt me at any point
if something's unclear or
if you wanna ask a clarifying question.
Let's see, okay, so I
wanna start by just noting
the extent to which for
the past several decades,
or really since we have
public opinion data,
the American public has generally been
opposed to welcoming refugees
or specific policies designed to bring in
specific refugees from specific conflicts,
even those in which the United States
has been very much involved.
So we have evidence on
this from World War II
with Jewish refugees from Nazi Germany,
but then also from Hungary in 1958
following the Vietnam
War in the late 1970s,
with Cuba in 1980 and then less so but
in 1990s with ethnic Albanians.
But the general pattern
here is one in which
opposition two refugees
has historically been
relatively high.
And we've seen this
very much continue into
more recent conflicts,
most notably with Syria,
so from polling by Gallup in 2015
at the height of the
Syrian refugee crisis,
37% of respondents
approved of welcoming
in more Syrian refugees,
but a fairly large majority disapproved.
So this is a consistent pattern
that we see over and over.
This did change to some extent
following the election of President Trump
when actually Americans over
those four years became more
willing to endorse immigration
and the admittance of
refugees specifically.
But what we did see,
which wasn't really as
pronounced in recent years
was a growing partisan
gap between Republicans
and Democrats, so over this period,
Democrats became more
supportive and Republicans
tended to become more opposed
to admitting refugees.
And these attitudes are
very much reflected in
the politics and policies
surrounding this issue,
so specifically with Republicans
becoming more opposed,
we saw around this time
as I'm sure you're aware
that Republican governors
were resisting efforts to
settle Syrians in their states,
and of course, infamously
Donald Trump's Muslim ban
was proposed in 2015 during
the presidential campaign ban
following the San Bernardino attacks,
but also linked to these
arguments about whether or not to
admit refugees from Syria.
So we do see that this
public opinion seems to drive
to some extent policy on this issue.
And what's also quite common
is to see that when
politicians are justifying
these sorts of policies,
there's a lot of misinformation
that gets trafficked
in attempting to persuade Americans to
be more restrictive in terms
of immigration or refugees.
So again, Trump's executive order
or Muslim ban was
implemented in some fashion.
And the way this was justified
was to talk about how,
in part how refugees or
those coming to the U.S
often don't get vetted very much at all,
and so who knows who's coming in,
who knows what kinds of
threats they might pose,
and of course this is
completely false in terms of how
the U.S goes about vetting refugees,
especially but this was a
cornerstone of the policy.
And even recently,
we saw this with the 2021
refugee wave of Afghans
coming to the United States
following the fall of Kabul
when former president
Trump at the time claimed
that there is no vetting
of refugees coming to
America from Afghanistan.
And again, this was very much false.
In this specific case,
it doesn't seem to have
been very successful
because this was a period
in which Americans were more
willing to support admitting Afghans.
So with all this prevalence
of misinformation
often used to justify and
promote anti refugee sentiment,
one common strategy
that seems common sense
for advocates and activists
is to publish information
trying to correct these misconceptions
in a very factual way.
So this is an example of one such article
from Human Rights First in 2016,
where they say top three myths
about the U.S refugee
resettlement system dispelled,
and then they go through those
in quite a lot of detail.
And so in this project,
the primary motivating
question is whether,
and in what context the provision
of this sort of correcting information
can actually change
recipients misconceptions.
And so the first order question here is
when you provide this sort
of factual information,
do you actually see individuals
update and correct their false views.
But then second and
perhaps more importantly,
we're interested in whether
this correction of information
has broader spillover benefits
to reducing prejudice
and negative attitudes
towards out-groups, in this
case refugees specifically.
So you might think that when
you correct this misconception
about vetting and the
extent to which refugees are
looked at very closely
by the U.S government
that people might become less worried
about security concerns
and that this would
then spill over into their
hostility towards refugees,
perhaps their preferences
even on refugee policies
and maybe even their willingness
to take action on behalf
of refugees coming to the United States.
And then finally providing
information in this way
is only one strategy
that advocates have used
and that scholars have studied in terms of
trying to reduce prejudice
towards out-groups.
And one other common basket of strategies
ties to leverage empathy
specifically to generate
empathy for out-groups
and reduce prejudice in that way.
And so we're also interested in comparing
the relative effectiveness of
information provision relative
to these empathy strategies.
So talking a little more about
why information might fail to or it might
what the literature says about
this information correction
in general,
moving away from prejudice
reduction for a minute,
we do find that people tend to update
falsely held beliefs when it is corrected,
but when this starts to get political
or is tied into issues of controversy,
that becomes less the case.
And one area in which that is true
is with prejudice reduction.
And we have research on this question
about immigrants and refugees,
specifically finding mixed results
in line with that broader pattern.
So Facchini et al for instance do show
large positive effects
of information about how
immigrants would benefit
Japan's aging workforce
on Japanese citizens,
attitudes and support
towards more immigration.
But that tends to be a bit of an outlier,
other studies, for instance,
Adida et al show that
when you tell Americans how little
relatively speaking their country
did to welcome Syrian refugees,
this doesn't actually
convince them that the U.S
should be doing more,
likewise Sides and Citrin show that the,
when you correct people's misperceptions
about how many immigrants
there are in the United States,
which we might think would be linked to
how threatening they
perceive immigrants to be
that this doesn't actually
have much spillover into
how they view immigrants
or immigration policy.
So there are three reasons
in thinking through these mixed findings
for why this information provision may
fail to shift attitudes because of course
there are all sorts of
different information,
pieces of information that
you can provide people with.
And so the first may be that
the facts are just already
known to individuals,
maybe they won't even admit that,
but they already know what
you're trying to correct
and so it's just not that helpful.
The second is that the facts are new,
you are changing the way
they think about something,
but it's not actually relevant
to how they form attitudes
towards an out-group, for instance,
or the behaviors they might
take towards that group as well.
So if it is one of these two reasons
that generally explains the
null effects I just mentioned,
then finding the kind
of correct information
in the right context would
be an effective strategy
to perhaps increase
favorability towards refugees.
But of course there is a third possibility
for which we have a lot of
evidence in other contexts
which is that maybe the facts
are new and they are relevant,
but individuals biases
in terms of how they process information
causes them to resist
actually believing this new information
or to incorporate it into
how they're thinking about
these groups and if this
is generally widespread,
then we might not find this strategy
to be particularly effective.
There's another possible problem here
that we wanted to flag,
which is that correcting information
in some cases may be counterproductive
if it ends up finding threats
and getting people to think about concerns
they wouldn't otherwise
have thought about.
So if we think about
informational interventions
that are often used by advocates
or politicians talking about refugees,
they often cite the economic contributions
that refugees make to the
United States, for instance,
or the fact that there
is very low security risk
from bringing refugees in.
But in doing this,
you may actually inadvertently
raise the salient
of potential economic
and security concerns
or perhaps people will think that
others are concerned about
this maybe I should be too.
So I don't wanna pick on
anyone specifically here,
but I think this infographic on the slide
is a pretty good example of
something that could
have this sort of effect,
so here they say, refugees
are economic contributors,
clearly trying to address
the potential concern
someone might have that
refugees come to the country
and then subsist on
government support, et cetera,
don't actually help the economy.
And so they say the top three industries
that employ refugees are
manufacturing, the health
sector, and general services.
But in looking at this it's
possible, we don't know,
but it's possible that
someone would be well,
okay, maybe refugees are then competing
with Americans for jobs in
these very important industries
and so you've actually primed
an economic threat concern
that ends up being counterproductive.
So setting this information
provision aside for a second,
another set of strategies as I mentioned
for trying to reduce prejudice
or increase inclusive
attitudes and behaviors
is to leverage emotion
and specifically empathy towards
a member of the out-group,
to then have that broaden into
more inclusive attitudes more generally.
So there's a large body of research
showing that this tends
to be quite effective
including with regards to
attitudes towards refugees
and immigrants specifically.
So again, Adida et al show that
if you encourage people
to take the perspective
of a refugee fleeing from Syria,
that this might increase their willingness
to write a letter to the White House
advocating for lifting the refugee cap.
Likewise Broockman and Kalla
show that if you give people
the perspective of an
unauthorized immigrant,
show them what it's like
to be in that position,
that this can reduce negative attitudes
towards this group as well
in part by creating more
empathy for their situation,
and then work that I've done with
these same co-authors
as well as some others
shows that priming people on
their own family's histories
with migration can also trigger
empathy towards migrants today,
and perhaps then shape the
way they view immigrants
and immigration policy.
So we in this study wanted
to build on this work
with two questions
and I'll talk a little more
about these in a minute,
but the first was whether there might be
beneficial interactions
between providing information
to correct a misconception
and also generating empathy in the same
sort of prejudice reduction intervention.
So if we use these in tandem,
does that actually create better results?
And then the second is thinking about
how these empathy generating interventions
may work more or less effectively
with certain types of people
and specifically whether
individuals who just
tend to be more empathetic in general
respond more or less to
these kinds of interventions.
So on the first question,
again, the idea here is,
are there interactions
between providing information
and then trying to also
do this perspective,
taking perspective getting
to generate empathy?
And what we expected
going into this project
is that if you embed
information correction
in an empathy inducing narrative,
that this might help
guard against the negative
externalities of information
that I just discussed
or you might inadvertently prime threats,
but also then help with
information updating,
so get people to open up and accept
that their beliefs were
inaccurate and they update.
And then perhaps actually incorporate that
into how they're thinking
about refugees more generally.
And there are two reasons that in our mind
this may have this may have occurred.
So the first is that emotions do affect
how individuals integrate new information
into their attitudes.
This recent paper, for
instance, shows that
when people get angry,
they're less likely to
accept new information
that corrects a misconception
and that this has effects
on their political views.
And the second is that
the cognitive demand
of taking someone else's perspective,
or at least reflecting on it
can reduce reliance on stereotyping.
And so in this case,
when people get information
that counters a stereotype
or misconception they have,
they might be more
likely to then apply that
information and update their views.
And so these two
mechanisms to us suggested
that it might be possible to
essentially turn information provision
into a more consistent,
effective prejudice reduction
strategy by pairing it with
a narrative that at the
same time generates empathy
for a member of the out-group.
On the second question, which is, again,
whether these empathy
generating interventions
are more or less effective for individuals
who have higher or lower baseline empathy.
We went into this with somewhat
ambiguous expectations for
what might happen.
So there's actually research showing that
individuals with higher levels of empathy
who just tend to feel more
empathetic towards others
on a day to day basis might
actually have more empathy
specifically for in-group members
because those are the people
they relate most closely to.
And so when they're feeling empathetic,
that's mostly directed towards
someone they can relate to most closely.
And this might actually
have negative consequences
for inter-group relations.
If that empathy for their in-group
then essentially causes
negative views of the out-group
that they might perceive to be threatening
their in-group members.
And in this case,
it may be that when you
try to generate empathy
through these other interventions,
there's somewhat of a boomerang where
that empathy gets directed
towards the in-group,
and then these interventions
are actually less effective
for those with higher
levels of baseline empathy.
On the other hand,
if you are someone who is just
generally more empathetic,
that's probably going to make you better
at thinking about what it would be like
to be in someone else's shoes
and the ability to do
that might then create
more openness to updating your
views of out-group members.
And in that case,
we might expect that these
sorts of interventions
are actually more effective
among individuals with a higher
baseline level of empathy.
So just to step back and summarize
then what we're trying
to do in this study.
We're first interested in
seeing if we can identify
misconceptions that are actually relevant
to how Americans develop their
attitudes towards refugees.
So find that information that
people don't really know,
and that also should have an impact on
their views of the refugee
population in the U.S.
And then to see if in
correcting that misconception,
we can first actually get them
to update their false view,
and then second try more generally
to have that spill over
into prejudice reduction
and an improvement of
attitudes towards refugees.
And then the third is
whether we can make
that even more effective
again by essentially
shielding the information
in an empathy intervention,
so looking for that interaction
between this information
provision and using perspective getting.
And then finally looking at that
heterogeneous treatment effect,
so does this empathy treatment
also work more or less,
well, based on how much
empathy someone has in general?
So any questions at this point
before I get into the design?
Okay, so yeah, feel free to
interrupt if anything comes up.
So we try to answer these
questions through two surveys
that were done two years apart,
the first in the fall of 2019
with an n of approximately 3,500,
and the second in the fall of 2021,
so just recently with an
n of approximately 9,000.
These were not panel surveys,
so these are not the same individuals,
but they are samples
recruited through Lucid
which provides scholars
with an easy tool to
get surveys done online.
We feel this through Qualtrics online,
and they're representative
of the American population
on key demographic characteristics,
age, gender, income,
ethnicity, education,
region, and partisanship.
So these are not the
highest quality nationally
representative samples,
but they are representative
on certain characteristics
that hopefully let us
draw some conclusions
to generalize the American
population broadly.
The first study was
intended to measure baseline
knowledge and attitudes of respondents
about refugees as well as
immigrants in the United States.
And as I alluded to the goal here was to
identify important
misconceptions about refugees.
So we use this first
survey to simply see if
there are certain areas in which people
are particularly likely to be misinformed
about what the refugee
population looks like
in the United States.
And then the second study
included our information,
correction experiments,
along with that empathy intervention,
trying to build from the first study
to see if correcting the
misinformation from study one
actually has beneficial
effects on views of refugees.
So I'll somewhat briefly
go over the results
from the first study.
This is a table showing some
of the questions we asked
in terms of trying to get
people to at least guess
or say what they thought
the refugee population
in the U.S looks like.
So in terms of how many refugees
were admitted that year,
the median response was
20,000 and that's actually
remarkably close to the actual number
which was around 22,000 in 2019.
In terms of the percent of refugees
coming into the United States
who are women and children,
it's a slight underestimate
of about 10 percentage points,
but a majority of respondents
or an on average respondents
thought that about 60%
of refugees were women and children
compared to the actual percentage of 70,
between 2015 and 2017.
There actually was not
really an overestimation
of the percent that was Muslim,
so looking at the years,
2002 to 2016, on average,
about 32% of refugees admitted were Muslim
and the average guess for
our respondents was 28%.
This did drop under Trump to
16, but I think in general,
this is pretty close to what
it was for a long period.
And then there is a slight,
there is an underestimate on how many
Christians are admitted especially
for those years from 2002 to 2016.
In terms of English fluency,
we asked respondents to
basically add up to 100
in terms of how many
one percent of refugees
spoke English fluently when they arrived,
spoke some English or spoke no English,
and here respondents
were remarkably close,
at least on average.
So a slight overestimate actually
of how many speak English
fluently on arrival
and a slight underestimate
of how many speak no English.
In terms of whether refugees pay taxes,
the modal answer was not sure,
but more said yes than no
which is the correct response.
And so it's really when we get
to these security issues that
we start to see really
large divergences from
what the actual refugee
population looks like.
So we ask people the percent
of terrorist attacks since
1980, for instance, that
were conducted by refugees.
The actual answer is zero.
And the average response here was 29%,
so this is a big miss.
We also asked respondents how many months
of vetting the typical
refugee goes through?
The modal response was 6 to 12 months.
The actual response, the actual
answer is 18 to 24 months.
And this is also a pretty
substantial difference.
In terms of the likelihood that
refugees would commit crime,
it's actually, most respondents
did acknowledge that it
was an equal likelihood
and there is a bit of a
miss to origin countries,
so most said Mexico
and Syria would provide
the most refugees in
the year of the survey
when in fact it was the
DRC, Burma and Ukraine.
So there are clearly misconceptions here.
Some of this information is quite specific
and you might not expect
everyone to know it,
but even in those cases people
are getting pretty close.
But what we do seem to see
is a big miss in terms of how
much refugees are tied
up into security threats.
And so just to provide a
little more detail on that,
this is the distribution of responses on
the months of vetting
that refugees go through.
So again, the true answer
is here at 18 to 24 months.
Most of the distribution is
quite a bit lower than that,
especially with the mode 6 to 12.
And then again, there's a pretty big miss
in terms of the percent
of terrorist activity
from 1980 to the present
conducted by refugees.
So there are many people saying zero,
but quite a few are way
overestimating that percent.
And this is correlational,
so we can only take so much from it,
but there is some evidence that those who
miss on this security threat of refugees,
those who have the highest
misconceptions here
are much less likely to
have favorable attitude
toward refugees as you might expect.
So in terms of the feeling thermometer,
they're much less likely
to rate refugees formally.
They're more likely to
also say that refugees
might threaten national identity,
increase the risk of terrorism
and are a burden on the U.S.
We also in this survey
had to question where
respondents could donate money to
the Refugee Council USA or
another pro refugee group
or an organization that's been
active in promoting stricter
limits on refugees,
and again you see that individuals who
are more likely hold this misconception
are much less likely to donate
to the pro refugee groups.
And then finally like also
with policy preferences,
those who believe that refugees
don't go through as much vetting
or commit more terrorist attacks
are more supportive of the Muslim ban,
want more screening, want fewer refugees.
So this is not conclusive.
This may be reverse causation,
but it does suggest that perhaps
these security misconceptions are related
to how people are
developing their attitudes
towards refugees in the United States.
I see a hand.
- [Susan] Yeah, I was
wondering about some of the...
Some of the information that you compared
the attitudes to the factual information,
like for example, what struck me, refugees
engaging crime, having equal
likelihood of engaging in crime
and, you know, I don't
know that that, you know,
I've always heard otherwise.
And so, and there were a
couple of other things also
that you mentioned that
seemed off the mark,
but maybe I'm misinformed.
So I was wondering where you
got your information from.
- Yeah, so we actually looked
at a variety of sources
to make sure we have this right.
And frankly, several of these answers,
I would not have known exactly myself.
And so I think our idea here
is not that not to show that,
you know, this is a fairly
technical specific policy issue,
and to say that people should know exactly
what percent of refugees
are women and children,
or if refugees are equally
likely to commit crime
or less so or more so.
But in general, some of
these misconceptions,
if they're really large,
might be contributing to how people are
perceiving refugees as threats or not.
And so the fact that people
on average aren't so far off,
we thought was positive for some of these.
On terms of the crime,
one specifically there has been,
there have been recent papers published
looking at this question with
pretty rigorous research designs,
and basically what they're showing is that
as refugees come into an area,
there's a precisely estimated null effect
on crime rates increasing.
I think this is pretty
much the conclusion from
other sources as well.
I don't remember the exact citation,
but if you're interested,
I can provide it to you.
Likewise, with the women and
children, Muslim, Christian,
this we were taking directly from
U.S government statistics online.
- Thank you.
- Yes, I have a question also,
I mean, if this information
is divided by like
political affiliation and
also a bit related to that
is that, I mean,
I think it has become harder
for people conducting surveys
to sort to get to the,
the way people actually think if you are,
as, for example, their voting behavior,
I mean, they have been
quite some mismatches
on what people say and
what they actually do.
So I wonder if some of the information
that you are getting yourself might
experience the same problem as well.
- Yeah, that's absolutely a possibility.
So your first part of the question,
there are definitely
differences here, for instance,
between Republicans and Democrats
in estimating these differences,
like differences on crime
or terrorist activity,
or how many refugees are admitted
or the women and children, et cetera.
And part of that may be
answering in a way that justifies
more restrictive policies because
you prefer those restrictive
policies and then
want to answer in a way
that supports the policies.
Whereas Democrats might do the opposite,
which is that they want
more refugees admitted,
so even if they don't know the answer,
they're gonna just guess a low number
on the terrorist activity
question, for instance,
because that aligns with
the view they already hold.
So we're taking an agnostic stance on
whether this information is actually
reflects I guess you could
say their true beliefs.
We did not incentivize them
to definitely get it right,
we were just curious in
what they would tell us
their conceptions were,
and that's somewhat relevant to
what we then do in the second study
and how we set up whether
information provision
can actually reduce prejudice.
Because one of the reasons that,
you know, it may fail to
have an effect is because
even if the information
is new and relevant,
people just aren't processing it,
and we to preview a little bit,
that's kind of what we find.
So even though we basically update people
on months of vetting
and it doesn't seem to
have any spillover effects,
and that might suggest
that when people answer this question,
they're just providing the answer
that already aligns with their views.
Maybe they have a sense of the truth
and just don't wanna say it,
or maybe they don't just don't care.
And so it could be,
it's probably the case that
some of these answers are
driven by other considerations.
Because again, I wouldn't
expect most people
to have thought deeply about
the specifics of these issues.
That's probably asking too much.
And so where they draw their priors on
are gonna be informed by a
bunch of different sources.
- [Teresa] Thanks.
- So if there aren't
other questions there,
but although I'm happy to take them,
I'll move on to the second study.
Again, the idea here being
that we build from the first
to try and see if correcting
a misconception that
stands out in the survey
can have effects on
attitudes towards refugees.
So the structure of the survey,
we first ask demographic questions
and then refugee security priors again.
So we basically ask some
of the questions from
the first survey that I just talked about.
We then try to measure baseline empathy
using a questionnaire from Davis.
This is an old source about
how to measure someone's
general levels of empathy
to get at those heterogeneous
treatment effects I mentioned.
And then we assign people to
treatment groups or control,
followed by measurement of the outcomes.
So we have three treatment
groups here and a control group.
So the first treatment,
and I'll talk about these in more detail
is that correction
on vetting and security
checks specifically,
the second is providing a perspective,
getting narrative about a refugee.
And the third is simply combining
those two treatments together
to see if there is a
beneficial interaction here.
The control is a pure control,
so respondents don't
get assigned to anything
and they just proceed through the survey
to the outcome questions.
So this is what the information
treatment looks like.
Essentially, we chose to focus
on the vetting misconception,
where people are underestimating
how much refugees go
through security checks.
The idea being here that we could provide
the most credible
information to respondents
by citing government sources directly.
We thought this might have more weight
especially given that many of
the organizations mentioned
have fairly high levels
of trust in the U.S.
So we wanted to try
and make this treatment
as strong as possible
and thought that this
would be the way to do it.
So first respondents are
told that they will read
some information about the U.S
and that we would then
ref have them reflect
on what they read,
and the treatment itself
on the next page says,
according to U.S government
and non-governmental agencies,
refugees undergo more extensive
and thorough screening
than anyone else who travels
into the United States.
Biometric and medical data
are collected from the refugee
who is screened by, you know,
then a whole host of security
oriented organizations.
The average time for the vetting
process is 18 to 24 months,
but it can take even longer,
to view an infographic of
the process click here.
And that would open into a new tab.
So not many people actually clicked on it.
This is just a little more information
about what we've already told them
and to give the source even more clearly
if they were concerned about that.
But this is the information
that most respondents
in this treatment group were getting.
And then for the second treatment group,
we went with a perspective
getting narrative.
So the idea here is that
you take a narrative
from an individual of an out-group,
and you explain to people
what it's like to be in their shoes,
give a personal story
about how hard it might be
to be a refugee coming
to the United States.
We chose to go with a
hypothetical story here,
and we told respondents that
because we didn't want them,
we didn't want to
essentially use deception,
but what we did and I'll
talk about this a little more
is draw on real stories
to create this story.
The reason we wanted
to do the hypothetical
was to have as much control as possible
over the information.
So we have this story about Abdi,
who we say was once one of 26
million refugees in the world.
He flees war-torn Somalia
at a young age for Kenya
and then lives in a camp for nine years.
He says, it feels like a big jail cell.
They give you food, housing
and the rest will be
from the hands of countries
coming to help people like America.
You just pray to a Allah,
when am I going to leave this place?
We then talk about his
experience in the United States.
So how hard it was to settle in
and explain his background to people,
whether that's Ramadan or Eid.
Now, he has a business, he
runs his own accounting firm.
He does community service
and he likes music like Led Zeppelin.
So the first part of this is
to try and give the experience
of actually being going
through the refugee process
and the second then trying to integrate
and build a new life once
you've actually arrived.
- By putting, I mean,
some of the information
that you put about this
hypothetical individual,
aren't you already sort of
bringing up some of the biases
that people might have as well?
And then, so for example, I don't know,
one of the things that
they do in the labor market
is that they put anonymous their name,
because then if you associate certain name
with certain characteristics
of the people.
So obviously here you want
to get sort of the more of empathy
of what is the process to go through,
but are you also sort of, as I said,
the people that are already
have their own biases
bringing that or people
who have doubts about that.
- Yeah, that's definitely a possibility.
So for instance saying that he's Muslim,
there's lots of research showing that
people react more negatively to
immigrants who are
non-Christian in the U.S
that might prompt this,
you mentioned the economic competition.
That might also be the case.
But I think what the
prior research suggests
is that when you really humanize
people that often have
face negative stereotypes,
it seems like on average,
this is beneficial and that
is actually what we find.
And on the hypothetical part,
you know, if anything that
might weaken the treatment,
if they're like, well,
this isn't a real person,
why should I care?
So, whereas the information treatment
we tried to make as strong as possible,
this one we actually were okay with it
potentially being weaker.
And that's partly because
previous literature shows
that this sort of approach is
supposed to be more effective.
And we were really trying to see like,
can we make this information
provision helpful or not?
And so I'll go into this a little more.
The combined treatment essentially puts in
the information paragraph
after the part where Abdi is talking about
how it was coming to the
U.S, how long he had to wait.
This felt like a natural point
and then proceeded again to
what it was like trying to integrate.
So again, these are
hypothetical individuals,
but we did base these on
stories from real articles.
There were two articles
from the Courier-Journal in Louisville,
and then from NPR.
The first was about Louisville
immigrant share stories of terror,
love and courage on the road to America,
the NPR one, Muslims in America
telling their own stories.
And these articles are
essentially doing exactly
what our treatment is supposed to do,
which is giving people this perspective,
humanizing both Muslim
Americans and immigrants.
And we actually borrow real quotes from
these articles in real
parts of the stories.
So the Led Zeppelin part for instance,
was one of these stories,
the quotes about waiting
to come to the U.S
for all those years also were
from one of these stories,
going to Somalia at a young
age, losing parents, et cetera.
And so, you know, we
felt that that would be
most likely to generate this empathy
and humanize the individual,
but also to avoid deception
and just give credit to these articles,
we then did have a debriefing
statement at the end,
just saying that, you
know, you read this story,
this was based on real people
if you want to read more,
you can click here.
So after respondents were assigned
to one of these three treatments,
or if they're in the control group,
sorry, after they're assigned
to these three treatments,
we then ask them to please
write a short paragraph,
summarizing what you just read
and how you feel about it.
So we had two purposes to doing this.
The first was we wanted people to actually
think about what they had just read,
we wanted to make it as
likely as possible that
they would really take that
information into account
or really reflect on this story
and what that might mean
for the experience of being a refugee.
But the second reason also
was because we wanted this module,
we wanted the treatments to feel like
they could have been their
own modules in the survey,
that there was a question
to be answered about
reading the paragraph
so that when respondents
then went on to the outcomes,
it wasn't as obvious that
they had just read this story
because we wanted them to answer
these subsequent questions.
So we're trying to avoid
demand effects essentially
by building in this
question to the treatments.
So after one of the treat,
after the treatments
or if they're in their control,
they go to a new page and they
have four outcome measures.
So first do they actually
update their prior
on the extensive nature
of the vetting process?
How warmly do they feel
as far as refugees?
How many refugees do they
want to admit to the U.S?
And then would they be
willing to write a letter
to the president about their views
on how many refugees should be admitted?
So I'll go through each of these in turn
and then show the results
FOR each of them as well.
So the first question was, again,
you know, approximately
how many months of vetting
does a refugee grow through
before being resettled
in the United States?
If you do not know, please
give your best guess.
So this is a question that we had asked
on that very first survey.
We then ask it in the
beginning of the second survey,
and then we ask it again in the
end as part of the outcomes.
And we want to see if people actually
get the answer right on the second time.
And so this is what the results look like
with the distributions of
responses on the number of months
for the initial answers and the prior,
sorry, the prior answers
and the posterior answers
after the treatments,
these are the three treatment groups
and this is the control.
So as you might expect,
if there's no treatment,
the respondents don't update
at all, why would they?
The answers are pretty much identical.
However, if they receive the
information we give them,
they do correct quite a lot.
So now the distribution is centered around
the correct answer and most of,
most of that distribution
is on the correct answer.
For the perspective,
getting treatment only
where they read this story,
they don't update at all even though
we talk a little bit about how
long he had the wait to come.
So what I will flag here
is that we had expected
that people might become more open
to correcting their misconceptions
if we embedded the information
in that empathy narrative.
And we don't really see that
essentially the effect here is the same.
If the info is on its
own or in the narrative,
there's no added benefit to
trying to combine the two.
The second outcome is
trying to broaden out more,
getting closer to prejudice
or negative views of refugees
personally as people.
So we use a standard feeling thermometer
saying on a scale from 0 to 100,
where zero equals completely unfavorable
and 100 equals completely favorable,
how do you feel about refugees
who come to the United States?
So here what we find is
in the control group,
an average response of 62,
and providing that information
about the vetting process
doesn't really change this at all,
it's also 62.6.
So we might have thought
that convincing people
that refugees go through
this extensive vetting
would make them less worried
about security threats.
And therefore they might feel
more warmly towards refugees
because they don't see them
as threatening anymore.
But in fact, that doesn't happen at all.
There's no broader
spillover of the information
into these views of refugees.
However, these empathy narratives,
the perspective getting treatments
do raise the average feeling
thermometer score quite a lot.
So by an average of six percentage points
on the scale from 62 to 68.5.
And again, this is pretty consistent,
whether it's perspective
getting on its own,
or if that story about Abdi
is combined with the information.
And again, we don't see
any interaction here
where combining the two makes
them even more effective.
The third outcome has to
do with policy preferences.
So we tell them every year
the federal government decides
how many refugees to allow to be resettled
in the United States.
And we then give them some context
so they know what those
numbers have looked like
and how much they've bounced around.
We say this year the number
of refugees permitted
to enter is 125,000,
next year do you think the
number should be higher, lower,
or stay the same?
And so again,
information here providing
that correction on vetting
doesn't make people more supportive
of admitting more refugees, if anything,
there's actually a slight backlash here,
although that is not
statistically significant.
However, again, giving
the narrative about Abdi
does seem to make people more willing
to say they would want to increase
the number of refugees admitted
that's significant and
substantively fairly meaningful.
And again, combining the two
doesn't really do much difference
as we thought it might.
It's slightly higher for the combination,
but that difference is not significant.
And then finally we ask,
would you be willing to write a letter
to the current president's administration
advocating for your position
on how many refugees
should be admitted into the United States?
So they could say yes,
they would like to write a
letter supporting an increase.
Yes, they would like to write
a letter opposing an increase,
or no they would not
like to write a letter.
And if they said yes, in
support or opposition,
we asked them to actually write the letter
to make this as behavioral as possible.
And we said, and we
will send it anonymously
to the administration on their behalf
after completion of the survey.
So this is what the
results look like here.
And again, they're quite consistent where
correcting on vetting, if
anything has a slight backlash,
although again, this is not significant,
so you're not seeing that spill over,
however, the perspective
getting treatments on their own
and in combination with the information do
increase willingness to
write a supportive letter
for raising the refugee cap.
So to summarize these main
effects of the treatments,
we do find that misconceptions
on security threat
can be corrected,
whether that's information just
on its own blandly provided,
or whether that's embedded
in a perspective getting exercise.
However, that information on its own
doesn't really seem to improve attitudes
and behaviors relative towards the control
and recall here that we were trying
to pick a piece of information
where clearly people
often had it wrong and where
also it seems theoretically
and also from some of the
regression analysis we did
that this should be related
to attitudes towards refugees.
So we were trying to make
this as strong as possible,
but still it didn't really work
beyond just correcting the misconception.
That being said, of course it may well be
that another piece of information
would have been more effective
and maybe we just chose wrong.
The other hand,
we do find that perspective
getting on its own
or with information
really does improve
attitudes and behaviors
at least in the context of the survey,
making respondents more inclusive
in how they approach refugees
as people and also policies.
However, this doesn't actually cause them
to update their beliefs
about the vetting process,
which is not necessarily surprising.
So now I wanna talk about
the heterogeneous treatment
effects I had mentioned
in terms of whether that perspective
getting treatment specifically
is more or less likely to be effective
based on disposition empathy.
And so again, it could be that
those with more empathy actually
respond less well to this treatment
or that those with more empathy
respond better because they're
more capable of processing
the out-group's perspective.
And in fact what we see
for the three outcomes
where the perspective getting mattered
was that these effects were
much stronger among individuals
who had higher levels of baseline empathy.
So in other words,
people who are generally better
at empathizing with others,
were more likely to increase
their inclusive views
in response to the treatment
than individuals who
just for whatever reason
are less empathetic.
So this is what it looks like
with the feeling thermometer.
Among individuals who are below average
in their baseline empathy,
the perspective getting
exercise with Abdi increased
the average response on the thermometer
by about four percentage points.
However, among those with a higher level
of baseline empathy,
the average on the
thermometer almost doubled,
the treatment effect almost doubled
to eight percentage point.
So this difference is
significant and fairly large.
- Sorry, Scott are
these results sort of...
Are they the same by gender
or by other characteristics of
are they still obviously
find the same level of
positive, or for example,
you would find that one is
more than the other.
- So I believe we've
looked with partisanship
and it doesn't seem to
differ consistently.
And likewise, I'm not sure about gender,
but that would be a good
one for us to look at.
There definitely may be other
heterogeneous effects here
that we want to look at,
but this pattern does hold
with controls included,
it seems like as well as we can do,
since we're not randomly
assigning levels of empathy,
that this pattern does persist.
And I guess for me,
partly it's quite strong
because it's consistent
across those three outcomes.
So this is what it looks
like for the policy outcome
where you actually see a slightly
negative effect for those low in empathy
for the combined treatment
although not significant,
but you see quite large effects
and positive effects for
those high in empathy.
And then again, also with letter writing,
there's a slight boost for
those low and baseline empathy,
but there's a fairly large boost
for those high in baseline empathy.
So, you know, when we're
doing this analysis,
it may be that there's some
other omitted variable explaining
the heterogeneous effects.
We can't rule that out, but
it seems like on average,
those with a higher capacity
to empathize with others
in general are the ones
who are most likely to be
affected by treatments
that try to prime empathy.
And I do think logically that makes sense
and isn't so surprising.
So practically that might suggest that
these are the kinds of
people to target with these
exercises when you are
designing messaging.
So just to start wrapping
up in terms of implications,
there is some debate
over whether trying to
reduce prejudice generally
or change attitudes on
refugees and immigration is
better served by doing this
sort of information correction
or by trying to leverage
empathy about specific people
and their stories.
And our study is not the first to show,
but builds on others suggesting that
these empathy generating treatments
are more effective typically
than trying to correct people's
stereotypes or falsely held beliefs.
But again, those effects
seem to be stronger for
those with high baseline empathy.
And in fact, they may not
exist at all for those who
are lower on average and
in empathizing with others.
At the same time,
we do show that correcting
misconceptions is possible,
so when we told people
that the U.S government
does all this extensive vetting,
there wasn't that much
resistance to them agreeing
with that information and
updating their priors and saying,
okay, yeah, I had it wrong,
this is how much vetting
they actually go through.
So to the extent that we care
about correcting misinformation,
even if we're not showing in this study
that that has spillover effects
in other ways that we might care about,
it does still seem that it
is possible to get people
to update on these sorts of issues,
even when they're closely tied to
pretty touchy political
topics and debates.
And to us, the main takeaway here is that
interventions combining perspective,
getting or perspective taking
along with information
correcting misconceptions
may be the most effective at
addressing a range of outcomes
because even though we
didn't find an interaction
as we were expecting
where these treatments
became more effective
by combining them together,
the combined treatment was the one that
corrected people's misconceptions
and also had these effects on prejudice
through the perspective getting narrative.
So this may have practical implications
for messaging that's
emphasized by advocates.
If you're going to provide
information and update,
try to update people's priors,
you might want to work in
these humanizing stories
along with it
if your goal ultimately
is to increase support
for admitting refugees
alongside correcting those misconceptions.
Likewise, if you're going to humanize
refugees as part of a
prejudice reduction strategy,
then you might also try
and work in information,
make the most of addressing
as many outcomes as possible.
In terms of where we go next,
so we would like to think more
about heterogeneous effects
and do some exploratory analysis
and thinking about who these
interventions work best for,
we're only showing this
short term in the survey,
so it may be that these effects
dissipate pretty quickly,
in fact, they probably do,
so we may try to look at persistence
and then potentially we'd be interested
in trying to scale this up into
an experiment with actual
messaging in the field,
so that's potentially another step also.
So if there are comments or
suggestions along those lines,
I'd be happy to hear them.
So, yeah, I'll end there,
thank you very much.
Comments are welcome.
You can also email me directly here
and for the team of co-authors we do have
a nascent website that you're
welcome to look at as well
at this link.
Thank you.
- Yeah, thanks.
I'm trying to remember exactly
for your first experiment,
the what exactly how
you gave the information
concerning the misconceptions.
And again, I'm thinking about
crime versus refugee vetting.
What is the distribution
of those misconceptions?
And so I'm wondering why
you took refugee vetting
for your second experiment.
And if there's something to learn from
doing the experiment on a
misconception that is not,
I don't know that is not
the average misconception,
but where there is a lot of variety
in what that misconception is.
So getting at some of the
heterogeneous effects, probably.
- Yeah, so for the first study,
we simply asked people to
try and describe refugees
in terms of these characteristics,
sort of one by one is questions
throughout the survey,
so we didn't randomize anything here.
We weren't trying to incentivize
getting the answer right.
We just asked them to,
you know, say, give us,
please give us your best guess
for what percent of women
and children are for,
sorry, what percent of refugees
are women and children?
So and we also, we told
people explicitly, like,
if you don't know, just try
to give your best guess.
So there we were just
interested in seeing generally
what the misconceptions might be,
and for many of these answers,
there is a lot of variations, so,
this for instance is the percent
of terrorist activity
conducted by refugees.
Someone is saying a hundred percent
I like to believe that that is an effort,
a political statement, but maybe not,
but clearly there's a lot of
variation here that could be
played around with and I
do think if we replicate
a version of this study,
it might make sense to
use this misconception,
for instance, instead of the vetting one
to see how this looks with
a slightly different piece of information
that in some ways maybe even more direct
in terms of what people are worried about.
So I do think it would be valuable
to play around with different
types of corrections,
because again, one weakness
of this literature generally
is that there are a million different ways
that you can provide information
correcting different misconceptions.
And it's hard, you know,
we can think through theoretically
why certain information
might be better than others,
but it may just be that this was the wrong
piece to update people on.
So that is definitely a
consideration to keep in mind.
- [Susan] Thank you.
- Would you be trying or is
it part of the exercise maybe
going forward and also to
identify the people that are
more sort of have more empathy
because obviously then you
can sort of increase whatever
policy you're trying to do,
but I would not know how to do that.
I don't if you have thought about that.
- Yeah, that's a great suggestion.
We haven't, I guess thought about that,
so directly we have
analyzed the correlates of
higher or lower baseline empathy.
I am not remembering those precisely
so I don't want to say something
that might end up being incorrect,
but we have looked at that and
you can definitely say like
so and so is more likely to
have a high level of empathy,
but thinking through
perhaps how to identify
people with more empathy
in groups that aren't known for it
might be fruitful for instance,
so that's something that
seems we're thinking about.
- And what about the
characteristics of the individual?
Like, I think when I'm
trying to convince, oh, yeah,
I don't like to be called
chairman of my department,
and what would you think
if your daughter was,
you know, heading an economics department
and she were recalled chairman,
and it's because I can appeal to
that characteristic of him
being a father to a daughter.
And so what can you do potentially
in terms of learning how to
correct these misconceptions
and appealing to them?
- So one, in our previous work,
looking at family history,
we essentially try to do that because
basically all Americans
come from elsewhere,
not all, but most,
you can draw on that as
a sort of shared identity
or experience at some
point in your family's past
that people can relate to,
and we show that this might
increase empathy towards
immigrants coming in today.
So I definitely agree
that being able to link
your own experience to something
they've gone through themselves,
or at least tangentially
or related to perhaps
because their daughter has
faced gender discrimination
and they've seen it,
even if they're a man
who can't go through it,
then that will be perhaps more effective
as an intervention on that type of person
because they're just more able to relate.
So that may be the case
even for people who
don't have high levels
of baseline empathy,
if you can still find a way to
link the treatment to something
they have gone through personally,
they may be more able to
empathize than with the target
because they have some
sense of what it is like
to go through that.
And so in our earlier study,
we actually don't find
heterogeneous effects
based on baseline empathy
and I think that's in part because
even those individuals have
this shared family history
at some point migrating
to the United States.
- They still say, but
my family stood in line.
That's the response that they always say.
We're not standing in line
today, but they did back then.
My family did.
Even though they didn't,
we know they didn't.
- Yeah, definitely got
those responses as well.
But on average it seemed to
have some positive effect.
- I just have one comment,
so is that we're running
a survey about the seminars that we have
offered for this academic year,
so if people could just please
complete it and send it to us
so then we can prepare for next year.
And so thank you very much
to Professor Scott Williamson
for this wonderful presentation and
just sort of to broaden the
possibilities that we have
in order to change the perspective
of people about refugees.
So thank you very much, everyone.
And this is our last seminar
of the academic year.
Any question (indistinct)
- Thank you.